الاسباب التي ادت الى هذا التطور عندما
تتحدث صحيفه ديعو احرنوت نقلا عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان وزير الخارجيه بلينكن يعتقد
ان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي يسعى الى
المواجهه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ما المقدمات التي ادت الى هذه
النتيجه نتنياهو يود ان يواصل الحرب لان
هذا يساعده على البقاء في السلطه هو يود
ان يواصل الحرب حتى يبقي اليمين سعيدا
وهذا يتناقض مع ما يريده الامريكيون
نتنياهو يقول للامريكيين حتى الان وحسب
رايي هو يقول لهم لا لا لاي شيء مثلا يشبه
المقترحات الموجوده على الطاوله في الوقت
الحالي هو يرفض حل الدولتين هو كذلك يرفض
عمليه التفاوض مع حماس
ويرفض
الهدنه من اجل ادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه كل هذه الاشياء تجعله على عدم
توافق واتفاق مع الرئيس بايدن وهنا نعود
للسيد سليمان هل بات من المتاخر جدا ايقاف
نتنياهو في في خططه التي بدت واضحه الان
هو يريد الاستمرار في الحرب الدعم من قبل
اليمينيين المتطرفين هو الاكثر ظهورا في
الفتره الاخيره اذا هل بالفعل بيمين
نتنياهو لا يجد من يوقفه عند هذه
النقطه هو الان ربما يلعب بالاوراق
الاخيره التي بين يديه والتي يحاول من
خلالها اعاده خلط الاوراق مره اخرى ولهذا
السبب ربما ما شاهدناه وتابعنا الليله
الماضيه كيف ان بنيامين نتنياهو يبدو انه
يستقوي بالشارع اليميني عندما يكون هناك
تظاهره مضاده للتظاهر
المؤيده لابرام صفقه التبادل يكون هناك
مظاهره يمينيه ترفض هذه الصفقه وتدعو الى
استمراريه الحرب وهذا بالمناسبه يعيدنا
الى يعيد الاذهان الى ما جرى في ايه مارس
وابريل العام الماضي
2023 عندما ذهب بنيامين نتنياهو لذات
الاداه والاستراتيجيه عندما كان هناك
امكانيه او عندما كان هناك الحديث عن
الذهاب الى الاصلاح القضائي في اسرائيل
وكان هناك مظاهرات مندده و ومطالبه بضروره
اقاله بنيامين نتنياهو لجا مره اخرى في
ذلك الوقت الى الشارع اليميني للخروج
بمسيرات موازيه للمسيرات المطالبه بضروره
تنحي بنيامين نتنياهو الان بنيامين
نتنياهو واضح جدا كما قلت هو يستقوي
بالشارع اليميني اولا لتعزيز موقفه داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي وثانيا لمحاوله بعثره
او دعني اقول صد الضغوط الامريكيه هذا
الامر كله ربما هو يكون المحاوله الاخيره
لبنيامين نتنياهو امام الوقت الذي بات
ينفذ بشكل واضح جدا سواء فيما يتعلق
بالخيارات السياسيه او الخيارات الميدانيه
التي لم تعد ايضا متاحه بالنسبه ل
لنتنياهو كل هذه الامور هي ربما الدافع
الاساسي التي قد تجعل بنيامين نتنياهو
يتخذ قرارات غير محسوبه في الوقت الحالي
الهدف الاساسي منها كله فقط هو محاوله
التشبث في ال المرحله السياسيه المقبله
والتشبث ايضا بالخيار المجتمعي المتمثل في
اليمين المتطرف